gosh they're oh-yo about to run out of
here what's up
okay what's going on everybody first we
feast I'm Sean Evans and you're watching
hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today I'm joined by riff raff the album
peach Panther we've been teasing it for
about a year now but for real for real
it's coming out do we have a date
yeah June is July Yeah right around
there I won't well having a set date
presumably I don't want to guess you up
too much before we start but every time
we drop an episode people clamor in the
comments or online about who they want
to see on the show yeah and I think
you're probably the most requests for
real did they get a close-up Morocco
bear grill cuz I had to put these all
Tomas I know cuz you can't eat with the
aqua bear you can't mess up these
aquifers you get a blue glass you know
when I say swimming pool and mouth with
Jacuzzi diners well they can't save you
today now you're just on your own
biology oh you're ready to go man
leavers these wings alright let's make
the people proud you ready
just
first one sriracha no big deal you'll
take off these pinky right who got hmm
so speaking of peach Panther last summer
there was this clip that surfaced online
and it was you and Bieber in the car huh
and you're rapping the song he was sick
I just want to know if they're gonna be
so many chances I'm looking all around
and I've heard you say that Bieber is
gonna be on the next album and I've
heard you say that you don't have any
features on the on the next album
sometimes with you I don't know what -
blue can you level with me what's the
deal with this people I wish for sure
got ya damn the guy every song I have is
a to feature but I got a lot of soy
sauce to on there but you definitely got
features on there what about this Bieber
song I need to know more yeah Diplo
producer that's one everyone down aren't
you like a little bummed that maybe it's
not out now because you have your
buddies post and Justin on tour you
could be doing that song on this road
right now
you don't know how bad I would wanna be
on that tour you think about that
sometimes man every night Fargo sleep
okay
i sat on that post alone Justin Bieber
to it that were crazy so this one got
Tapatio household name no big Miller
corner notice were so every rapper talks
about shutting down the mall but you
really shut down the food court we at
first we feast we've written about it
quite a bit
you're not content with just a Styrofoam
plate with some chicken teriyaki in
there I want to know what's your former
top five pants where's it up there
chick-fil-a is up down your personal
ball yes I was Italian Oh auntie auntie
those pencils you can get the honey
mustard the marinara and you mix those
together
that's the move mm-hmm at aunt Annies
okay one more yeah I gotta go talk about
talk about top five for sure
number three how you feeling so far
Jesus Christ
I'm Kyrie Lu techo Caribbean hammer oppa
and you're also Somali a of sodas that
might be your favorite my favorite thing
that you do you know how you'll pair
fruity pebbles
with monster energy drink right you [ __ ]
with cinnamon toast crunch a lot of time
for fun what would you pair us them in
toast crunch
you poor horchata you know cinnamon
toast crunch what about Apple Jacks
Applejack go sour apple poor logo luck
Cookie Crisp Kogi Chris you mess with
Cookie Crisp you go on oh but no
approach docile milk yeah like a monster
muscle up goddamn that dad number three
was getting up there well you got a ways
to go
yeah yeah all right so this is Pena's
girl [ __ ] louisiana-style
how you feeling now my up done do this
down but right here she's getting kind
of spicy
alright cool let's go so last month I
saw you swing a wrestling match for a
boy Rey Mysterio right I know that you
bolt you're barely fitting into the suit
jacket you know I gotta get a new one
made pretty soon yeah you might have to
get that custom because it was hacking
on the pound Python comin through we're
probably on beat Python for sure gonna
split it at the seams and I know it's a
dream of yours to be a wrestler but I
wonder to what extent have you thought
it through do you have a wrestling name
picked out peach make a neon Python
okay Joey how old
Hey mr. Lamborghini leglock okay aqua
Barry back fist neon knuckles ma'am we
got along this have you thought about
the persona what would your persona man
I'm just me like like those are what
people are saying Jodie Howell riff raff
you're talking about the same person you
know hey like James Franco's Nick like
James Franco's nickname is riff raff
comes in like it's like you're saying
[ __ ] are you still bugged by that y'all
care no but I don't every can about do
you know what bother me about that if I
were you though is that is that one what
Spring Breakers - needs to come out and
I play that uh I was James Franco's um
twin brother who was in jail and then he
gets out to revenge his death yes that
would be basic step round already I know
sounds like you read that script or
something else crazy well cuz what would
bother me is you know should be you
getting these roles not man Franco
[ __ ] plain man you'd say who you
gotta talk to the director about that
alright so this fifth one is actually
our hot sauce the top ones hot sauce
it's made by our friends homeboys hot
sauces out of Phoenix you can pick it up
at heat inist you can pick it up online
literally the greatest hot sauce ever
made but riff raff I'll let you be the
judge of that
Omaha so what's the best piece of advice
Hulk Hogan ever gave you about getting
it done in the weight room
how is your mom passed away that's good
to hear a good thing is work out in the
mornings like as soon as you get up
don't even think about just make it part
of your schedule like I'm wake I'm
waking up and I'm working out for 30
minutes you know I mean I'm waking up
and I'm like have a little set schedule
with you um at this time doing it was
hard on tour sometime how you feeling
man
we're halfway through um I'm gonna make
it what are you coming in that now
thirty to forty I'm not to forty i
fluctuate though i started having
trouble tie my shoes if I know it's time
to kind of chill out logo what other
downfalls have there been to putting on
that kind of those kind of gains cuz
that's no joke yeah just like having a
constantly bike spend money on new
clothes cuz I'm not I can't fit in my
clothes like
if you see right now I'm damn near
busting out of this Marc Jacob jacket I
wasn't what are you gonna do with that
huh are you gonna do this yeah all right
when you're working these kind of
pythons like it's like it doesn't it
just doesn't happen overnight I can
barely even drink his beer hold on sir
you have a straw
you gonna strong enough no sure do you
have any style advice for husky boys
keep it comfortable cut the sleeves off
don't don't don't try to get too fancy
and go sleeves all right uh-huh
just go just give us a snip them shits
off not rip them off because then you're
still gonna have the undercarriage I'm
just gonna cut you in the under
cartridge you got a start down low yeah
I have a certain way up cut if you had a
shirt and a suit I'll show you exactly
what our burly would pull both sleeves
right there number four or five inches
down
no notice that no no notice that notice
that curvature then hold up that's bad
nice run for sure
you ready I'll get burly I'm ready okay
you're right good now those officials
how hot one shirts that's how the bird
would go there we go you ready to move
on all right so this is High River rogue
and toss on it look like you're trying
to take me out with this one we had
currency on here and we were talking
about rap dogs when your boy riff Raff's
jody husky [ __ ] that was a dog like this
they chased me to school every day we
named him Jack the woof I believe he was
a man up in the Siberian or maybe an
Alaskan male news or something but we
ran from him all the time now that we
have our doing here I need to know more
I was a bit video shoot and I saw Jody
and he was sitting in somebody's on this
true story
he's spitting something on a cop car
after Huskies that day and he's just
sitting there he wasn't you know like
most puppies they wanted jumping around
and playing and run around he was just
sitting there just looking around I was
like something about that husky I got
you know I mean I saw something you you
had a connection
yeah and I went through the video shoot
we did it we did the photo he was on the
front cover of neon icon that was him
that was that was my baby but that was
him so so I asked the dude I was like
how much for that dog
he's like thousand dollars I was a cool
megiddo drop but that time I was I'm
saying I had a condo I was in Hollywood
there was no you can have pets I
remember but I remember I woke up the
next morning and I was thinking about
that dog I like parking it I caught
media calling bottom rest is history
holy spice guys moving on to eight dozen
by the Lambs home kind of scare this
never go so this one is the bomb
yeah insanity it's not what wasn't I
wasn't describing it well I think I'm
wrong pain that's poor oh yeah you are
on pain are you doing next one I'm on
the docks ask me yeah I did
damn I'll show you're busy we're talking
about Jody I guess the key is to just
hurry up with these damn answers and
just start jumping more I talk to warm
all right cool all right really is month
you might announce this for
million-dollar neon nation deal right
says that you're gonna be the music
executive with the artists and these
deals I never really understand them
like jay-z and title oh and I read about
him and never understand first off what
does that deal mean exactly
I don't think there's a lot of artist
development or a lot of art like to my
watching over artists and making sure
that every single thing they do is right
I want to be more in charge of that when
I saw to that you're like this is the
record label this is a talent oh yeah oh
yeah I'm signing I'm not just signing
just music artists I'm I might sign if
you if you if I like the idea it's like
shark tank you know I mean if I like
your idea I think we can make money
that's what we're gonna make money
let me ask you this what if you met some
guy who had a wing show on YouTube right
go on
yeah yeah what if you don't want to open
up oh wait yeah what would you say to
that guy
first of all number if I can get through
this got now tip these wings now you
look at wing challenges are actual
[ __ ] that could be a show that should
be on an age of HBO or something one I
want to be at the top of your list okay
riffraff
I'll tell you what if I will how wins on
this so you're the man
you got it I mean so much to me
Mad Dog 357 is number nine holy [ __ ]
oh boy you cleared those beers yeah how
many other thing I'm in Jesus wort 5d
gee you have a song with little yachty
yeah under yeah you know right now yeah
and what I've always thought is
interesting about you is got a lot of
rappers will reference athletes right
but everybody says like Kobe and LeBron
and what I've always liked about you is
your references are always a little bit
more obscure so specifically I wanted to
bounce a couple 90s baseball players off
of you that you seemed to be interested
in and you can tell me why they inspire
you okay Julio Franco hey what I forgot
to quit oh man getting dangerous over
here
why are you inspired by Julio Franco
well hope I don't feel free clay but
x-rays out his used to be cranking
homers in a wild batting stance it was
crazy
do you think that Major League Baseball
is kind of better when everybody was
just on the juice man it was all juiced
up it's kind of like a WWF but with
baseball bats just balls flying out all
over the place I kind of wish that
everyone would just give it a concierge
the Sammy Sosa Mark McGwire the best
you're going back to back jack man I'm
uh oh there I go yeah you got one more
wing bro
perhaps y'all will have that for sure
five oh man oh wait do we have one more
lap graduate yeah one more go it's
tradition around here it's dad the last
one you don't have to but I will oh how
you doing not so good you guys gave it
up be careful don't put too much oh man
that's good that's good
gosh dear oh you're about to run out of
here what's up all right come on holla
good but it was the biggest
misconception about riffraff you will
think I save over money as soon as I get
I spend it we're gonna ask me for [ __ ]
of our [ __ ] Sparrow from super trip
all right amazing episode you made it
all the way through from zero impressive
and in a suit the floor is yours
30 seconds let the people know what you
got going on in your life probably peed
pants are coming soon movie console pee
pad call Slim is out now holy [ __ ]
and that's about it
these pants are sign at all I might take
this [ __ ] bowtie off me for real take
it off I can't do it take that [ __ ] off
oh my god
wait what I thought that movie was
humming with my that movie was fire you
got how about two or three parodies you
know if you don't these wait I'm gonna
struggling on workouts that one just
bites your ass
wow great raps bottles do is the first
time amazing I feel like these are the
best Jordans